>> SHANNON: BREAKING TONIGHT,
TEXAS REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTS ISSUING A DISASTER DEREK
CALCULATION OVER THE BORDER
CRISIS.
IT'S THE FIRST SUCH DECLARATION
FROM ABBOTS.
TONIGHT WE CONTINUE OUR
REPORTING ON THE DANGEROUS
CRIMINALS ENCOUNTERING MENTAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ALONG THE
BORDER.
THIS EVENING, THE PURSUIT OF A
SMUGGLER CARRYING MORE THAN A
DOZEN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN A
SINGLE VEHICLE.
HERE'S MORE FROM MISSION, TEXAS.
>> A SMASHED UP BLACK SUV
COVERED IN DIRT SITS ON THE SIDE
OF A HIGHWAY AFTER ROLLING OVER
DURING A HIGH-SPEED POLICE
CHASE.
INSIDE 17 MIGRANTS BEING
SMUGGLED INTO THE U.S.
THIS IS ONE OF 300 VEHICLE
PURSUITS TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS ENGAGED
IN SINCE MARCH IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY.
BUT SMUGGLERS AREN'T JUST MOVING
PEOPLE.
>> CHECK OUT THIS PARTICULAR TO
BE VIDEO GIVEN TO FOX NEWS BY A
LAW ENFORCEMENT SOURCE WHO SAYS
IT APPEARS TO SHOW MULTIPLE DRUG
SMUGGLERS CUTTING IN AND OUT OF
VEHICLES.
MEANWHILE, MORE DETAILS ARE
COMING OUT ABOUT BIDEN'S WIDE
REACHING PLANS TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO ENTER THE U.S.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" OBTAINING A
BLUEPRINT DATED MAY 3 ENTITLED
DHS PLAN TO RESTORE TRUST IN OUR
LEGAL IMMIGRATION SYSTEM WHICH
LISTS POLICY PROPOSALS LIKE
SHORTER IMMIGRATION FORMS AND
FEWER SECURITY CHECKS TO HELP
MORE FOREIGNERS MOVE TO THE
UNITED STATES INCLUDING HIGH
SKILLED WORKERS TRAFFICK
VICTIMS, FAMILIES OF AMERICANS
LIVING ABROAD, REFUGEES, ASYLUM
SEEKERS AND FARM WORKERS,
SEXUALLY UNDOING MANY TRUMP ERA
IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
FORMER ACTING ICE DIRECTOR
TOM -- SAYS HE SAW THIS COMING.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION LEGAL.
THEY ARE GOING TO CHANGE THE
ASYLUM RULES BECAUSE 90% OF
AMERICANS WHO CLAIM ASYLUM DON'T
GET RELEASED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
QUALIFY SO THEY WILL CHANGE THE
RULES AND MAKE IT SO THEY
QUALIFY.
>> SHANNON, THE NEW DISASTER
DECLARATION HERE IN TEXAS MEANS
THE GOVERNOR IS NOW SENDING IN
MORE STATE AND LOCAL RESOURCES
TO HELP COMBAT T